yesterday will smith resigned from the
academy of motion pictures arts and
sciences he wasn't going to but then
jada gave him that look
[Music]
you know i trended on twitter that day i
was i trended i wasn't even there
nothing to do with me because people
were saying what would what would ricky
jerez have said what would what would
have happened with your face well
nothing and
i said this live i said nothing would
happen to me because i wouldn't have
told
a joke about his wife's hair either told
a joke about her boyfriend
i'm gonna say some horrible [ __ ] up here
i should warn you guys now but you know
just don't will smith me you know
yeah yeah that was ugly huh holy [ __ ] i
think we should change the term from
karen to jada
yeah
yeah
oh yeah
[Applause]
yep man that was wild [ __ ] left on
television next year the option is going
to be produced by dana white yeah
even putin was watching that [ __ ] going
dude little violent over there huh holy
hell
i still think it's weird that you know
will smith was front row and there's no
stage if he was in the fifth row that'd
be a whole different dynamic you know if
you're gonna be like excuse me hold on i
gotta get down yeah
watch it tom hanks all right there we go
okay
yeah crazy the whole thing's great i'm
just glad you know he uh chris rock
didn't make fun of alec baldwin's wife
that could have gotten a little uglier
you know
yeah
all right
i mean that [ __ ] was crazy even kanye
watched it like oh man that guy's lost
it oh yeah
yeah
yeah chris rock deserves the oscar for
acting normal
you know i got called a homo once at a
college gig i almost killed myself so
oh hey thank you sir appreciate it hope
you didn't cosby it all right thank you
but but that's what's amazing to me is
that rage when you're in when you're in
rage that's all the karen's will went
full karen yes he couldn't control it
right it's rage man and rages rage is
like like okay let's talk about the
feelings the best feelings in the world
full rage when you're shaking you feel
like a superhero and you think i will
[ __ ] rip this wall down yeah that
yeah being turned on when you're like oh
my god i'm so turned on i could [ __ ]
yeah your body's vibrating
um thank god he didn't feel that toward
chris that would have been even worse
how great would he be if he just [ __ ]
just anally raped him on that stage jada
would have been like finally
that's all she wants but that was rage
it was he was drunk with rage and
and who knows what had happened leading
up to that all the stuff leading up to
it yeah they clearly didn't like they
clearly had tension because yes because
you think about what rickles used to say
to sinatra the biggest egomaniac ever
he'd say things like hey frank make
yourself at home hit someone and sinatra
would laugh yeah so it's all about past
relationship you know well did you see
the 2016 oscars where rock trashes jada
it's pretty funny it's pretty funny but
it's like oh okay so there is some
history here she was boycotting the
oscars because will didn't get nominated
and i don't remember the joke but a joke
because it's not fair to get nominated
it's also not fair he got 20 million for
wild wild west and then it's not fair
she goes uh he's like you're not
boycotting you weren't invited i'm not
boycotting rihanna's panties
[Laughter]
that's an edgy joke for the oscars i
know that's one you probably can't get
away with these days no it was a
different time just 2016 to now is is
vastly different jaina got mad
jada says she's not coming
protesting i'm like is she on a tv show
jason's going boycott i said jaden
boycott in the oscars is like me
boycotting rihanna's panties
i wasn't invited
listen you might hear some things
that you don't like
[Music]
i'm not saying that i can fight
i will bite your [ __ ] nose off
i'll fight your tits
off was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore i'd i'd
for announced this morning that i was
suing will for 200 million dollars
because that video is going to be there
forever it's going to be ubiquitous
you know that insult is going to last a
very long time if you want to yell from
the audience and disapprove or show a
disapproval or say something on twitter
or whatever you you know you do not have
the right to to walk up on stage and
smack somebody in the face because they
said words i support chris
uh
also it sucks i always like jada pinky
she was great in a nutty professor as a
love interest and she was great and uh
big lebowski is the bowling ball
you want to hear something funny i i saw
a tweet that said it wasn't even rock's
joke it was one of the writers that's so
good what do you think he's doing
backstage but after the writer just like
here's the thing yeah the writer
probably thought of way worse jokes
about infidelity and was like let's go
with something mild dude she's wearing a
green like a military green outfit yeah
and is she going to be in gi jane
no no no they're not making another gi
jane
no no she's not doing this for a role
what
what do you mean
what do you mean no no she's doing it
because she has alopecia she's losing
her hair yeah which is apparently a huge
deal i had no idea
every person at the oscars has fake hair
every person in this room is losing
their hair yeah yeah shout out to keeps
but no for real like if there's one
place where you can wear like wigs and
fake hair and all that kind of stuff
it's the like every girl there probably
has extensions yeah but she wanna be
proud she wanna come out and say yo this
is my hair well they're keeping them up
he was doing some weird movie thing it
was like he was getting away with it as
if he was living in a fictional movie
like the idea that you think it's smart
while wearing a tuxedo to walk onto a
stage in front of the world like
literally the world one of the biggest
award shows on earth if not the biggest
and smack a comedian for the most mild
joke and then sit there quivering saying
keep my wife's name out of your [ __ ]
mouth and everybody's just gonna sit
there in the [ __ ] that you just took on
the table you just pulled your pants
down and took a [ __ ] on the dinner table
and they all have just sit there and
look at that that's what it's like
full of peanuts and corn and everything
it stinks it's just the whole idea
behind it is completely irrational but
what i'm saying is like these people
live in this
fake world of you know you're you're
protected by guards you're driven by
limos you're on the red carpet you know
like all of it is crazy life and he's so
goddamn famous and so
so removed from regular discourse and
interaction with regular people that he
for whatever reason in his head acted
like he's a character in a movie